the transhumans agenda for those that
can afford it is you're going to be able
to remain in your biological body and
the advancements will allow you to at
least double your lifespan a lot of
these things people think that you know
Jared Kushner went on television two
weeks ago and said my generation is
either going to be the first to live
forever or the last to die now Jared
Kushner has billions of dollars to spend
on that the vast majority of us don't
the same people that are investing in
that technology via things like Calico
which is run by Kurzweil in his alphabet
or Google's company on immortality then
you have the people that want you to
merge with the machines and this is kind
of the digital human or mind clone
aspect of it so at one aspect the very
rich believe that they're going to be
able to stay in their biological body
but then they're going to try to
acclimate the rest of us to accept
things like neuralink human brain
interfaces and Beyond to the point where
they get the populace to believe that
they can actually upload their
consciousness